My name Kristen, so
I'm at Irrational Labs right now.
At Irrational Labs how many
of you know Dan Ariely?
Great.
So, he's a kind of famed author,
professor at Duke.
And kind of a thought leader, he is
a though leader in behavioral economics.
So what Irrational Labs does is
try to merge this understanding
of human behavior, human psychology,
and then teach products that are trying
to change the world how to better improve
their users lives through understanding
the psychology of their users.
Partly trying to take the academic world
and say, hey folks, there's learnings
over here that you guys should be trying
to pay attention to while you go try and
build products that will
change people's lives forever.
So, how we do that?
We don't like to say consulting but
we help companies do this.
We're helping Google, we've helped Intuit,
Netflix, Fidelity, Lyft.
And basically they come to us with
all sorts of problems from trying to
increasing willingness to pay,
to helping people save money,
to helping people save time,
employing motivation, you name it.
And you think about the stuff that's in
the academic world about understanding
human behavior, and it can be applied
to help them solve their problems.
We also do events.
So every year, we'll have start ups and
academics get in a room and hang out for
about three days and
basically share insights.
And they walk away with the experiment
designs to the academics learn what folks
in the real world are doing and
the products people actually have a theory
that can shortcut a little
bit of their road maps.
And then most recently,
I'm very excited about this,
on Monday we're releasing workbooks.
So we basically, took the last year and
a half and said, very nice, and
you can definitely read Daniel Kahneman,
Thinking Fast and Slow, Dan books.
But in general, there's still
this kind of missing link between
how we talk about the learnings of
human behavior and product folks.
And so these workbooks are our effort,
there's about ten of them.
And they go through key behaviors and
incentives and
pricing and
social proof to try connect the gap.
It is literally we want
people to print this out.
I know this is crazy.
I don't even know what I'm thinking.
But thinking is you would sit in
a room with your product team and
think about how do you intervene
in a users life to help them
to bridge this intention and action gap.
And trying to give the folks the tools
to do that versus just talking three or
five users.
Which is very nice, very insightful but
we think there's probably a better way.
And that's kind of what I'm going to talk
today about is there's a better way.
So as a product community, you know, we
can, we're trying to change people's lives
and I think that we could be doing
it in a more successful way.
The one way we could do this,
oops, I just ruined it.
So we could start by looking at
the product and basically say what
are principles of product development that
would help us design better products?
But what I propose, because behavioral
economics is really about the study of how
people make decisions,
that we take more lessons from life.
So, I'm going to share some lessons from
my life, and then we'll apply it and
figure out how to scale that out into
principles of product, product and
behavioral design thinking.
So obviously,
every good story starts with the womb.
And so I'm a twin.
That’s me, this is my sister and
we're fraternal twins.
And if you don't know about fraternal
twins what happens is that about 99.95% of
our DNA is the same just like sisters.
But the thing about fraternal twins is
that we share basically everything, right?
So, we shared bunk beds, obviously
parents, lunches, clothes, classes,
sports, transportation to and
from school, like everything, right?
Actually, so the funny thing,
I told my sister this litter spiel for
the slide last night.
And so this is what I'm going to say and
she's like Brittany we shared everything.
And then she looks at me, Kristen we
shared everything except boyfriends.
Like this is a very on point comment, and
then we looked at each other and said,
actually one, and I was like,
wow, that's, [LAUGH],
I'll share that with the class tomorrow.
And so, but if you think about this,
and how similar we are.
This is what we look like now, this is
my sister she is a yogi, meditative,
like somebody who's
like pure San Franscio.
Like this girl she just represents
the culture of yogis in San Franscio and
I'm this professional multitasker,
I leave during stretching exercises.
Yeah, at the end of workouts,
I could be doing three things.
But if I'm doing one, this is terrible.
And you think about how actually
we became so different.
And in reality, it's that, and
this is kind of the first lesson here.
We have small details
make a big difference.
All right, so the very small
details obviously in our DNA and
in our environment make a huge
difference on the outcomes of our lives.
We'll go on to the next one.
So other big decisions and
maybe this has hit you guys before.
Coming to Stanford,
it'll hit you after but at some point,
you have to make a decision
about where you want to live.
And so after school, I had a job offer
from a nice consulting company in Chicago.
Or I was going to go with Intuit and
hang out in San Francisco.
And so the obvious thing, you look at
how much they're going to pay you.
And Intuit is paying me $9,000 more and
as any college kid I was like this
is a very good deal,
$9,000 more in San Francisco, fabulous.
And then you think,
well this is a terrible way to
think about the world, [LAUGH].
San Francisco is actually much more
expensive as I soon found out when
I got here.
I looked this up and
it's 100% more for bread.
[LAUGH] And it's 78% more for rent.
But what I did is something
called this money illusion.
So you take x and you take x plus 9,
and then you say which is better?
Now you have something that's better.
It's a very easy to do equation.
But the reality is that's
not what I should have done.
Despite the cost of living,
you think about what I should
have paid attention to.
And you know, the commutes.
I'm living in San Francisco,
going to Mountain View
commute is not one of the things that
increases our happiness by any means.
The culture, so you have all these
text folks in San Fransisco.
You've got kind of like
the Midwest corn playing
dodgeball after work folks in Chicago.
And then, the other thing is
obviously this concept of mating.
Possibility this is what you should look
at if your planning on
making a long term decision.
They'll have impact.
And there are more men in
San Fransisco less in Chicago.
But then again, as I was doing this
research, I realized I include engineers.
>> [SOUND]
>> I know.
[LAUGH] Just kidding guys.
Totally kidding.
Seeing how that would go.
[LAUGH] Okay, so the point of this though.
You're moving across cities,
huge life decision and you're paying
attention to what you're paying attention
to incorrect math in only one factor, but
it's the most salient factor.
And so, I actually was using my
gut intuition on this, in theory,
one of the biggest decisions
that I'll make in my life, or
one thing that determines
outcome the most.
Okay so, the next kind of life epiphany
only happened about six months ago.
And so six months ago,
I started using Stitch Fix.
Do we know Stitch Fix?
Trunk club for men.
So these are services
that ship you clothes.
You try them on, and
if you don't like them you ship them back.
Kind of crazy, right?
So it's like a Zappos, but
instead of you going and ordering,
they literally just ship you
a ton of clothes, six items.
I don't know what Trunk Club does, ship
you items and then you ship them back.
Before Stitch Fix, I didn't get any
compliments on my clothes, nothing.
And I realized the reason I signed up for
Stitch Fix is my roommate,
I got a new room mate and
she's very, very stylish.
She's like a person, for females.
Like it's like, she has toe polish,
she has nail polish on her toes
that matches like her bag.
This is the extent of how
stylish this woman is.
I was really why don't I do this?
And it's not that I don't want to be.
Stylish, that looks very nice, right?
Like who wouldn't want to look very nice,
this is great.
What I realized is that it
was actually a lot of work,
being stylish is a lot of work.
And so
it's not that I didn't want to be stylish,
it's actually there was a ton of friction
involved with me wanting to be stylish and
me actually being stylish.
And so Stitch Fix comes along,
ships me clothes.
I have them, I try them on and now like
literally before six months ago I was
wearing black and this is the only
time that I would get compliments,
and now I'm actually now I'm
pointing them out so you have to,
hopefully it passes the bar of just
being better than just all black,
but in reality it also
makes the decision harder.
And if you think about that decision and
no way could Stitch Fix could be better
at deciding what I would like than I am,
right?
I've answered five question questionnaire.
How could I possibly like the stuff
that Stitch Fix sends me more than me
infesting looking for clothes that
would actually fit and look nice on me.
In reality its a lot of work to have to go
shopping versus actually having
them shipped back to you.
So here's kind of the assumption,
the environment around me,
I moved in with my roommate, I realized,
holy **** there's another world out there
of style that I could be in, right?
Isn't that what we all think?
I avoided friction, it take a lot of time,
and then the concept of
actually just having to give stuff up
made me follow through with it, right?
because I'd have to ship something
back and I had already tried it on.
Okay, so what I'd like to pause it
here is basically that the fabric of
human decision making is not
necessarily big principle but
it's what we, the mistakes we make
in our day to day life, right?
So how humans behaves is not
this abstract concept but
it's how we make decisions and
how we fail to make good decisions, and
how this could impact our future and
our outcomes.
And so as someone positing this you'd say,
well this is actually true?
Where's your proof?
And so now we'll kind of go through
what the academics have said about
what these life lessons are in
the fabric of our decisions, and
figure out how we can apply
that to the product world.
Okay, so this is,
any vegetarians in the audience?
Okay, so you won't like any of these.
But when they surveyed people
about which one they like more,
it turns out without the label, equal.
We start calling something 75% lean and
25% fat and all of a sudden the world
changes and people are very,
very negative about the 25% fat label.
Now in reality nothing has changed, these
burgers are the exact same piece of meat,
and yet we kind of change our whole
frame of mind just on the small details.
Of all the things that I think that
the behavioral economics world has
given folks is this paying
attention to the small details and
how it will change big outcomes and
big behavior.
Okay, so this is can we incorrectly pay
attention to what's easily measurable?
Our gut intuition is not always right.
Okay, so at some point in your life,
I don't know,
I gave a talk and asked people how
many people have bought houses, and
everyone raised their hands, I'm guessing
in this room, has anyone bought a house?
We have one house buyer,
two house, three, awesome.
So other people can imagine a world
where you have to buy a house.
I know its not going to happen in San
Francisco for many of us at anytime soon.
So small house, big house, these are the
kind of decision you have to understand
what are your preferences
in buying a house?
Anyone have an idea of what
would go into making up someones
preferences of purchasing a house.
That is one of the biggest
decisions people will make.
>> Family size.
>> Family type, great.
>> No, size.
>> Family size, okay, yep.
>> Location.
>> Location, yep.
>> Price.
>> Size?
Size, yep.
>> Clean schools.
>> Cleaning, schools, cleaning,
so the size basically, yeah.
Preference for cleaning,
how much you like it or you don't like it.
We've kind of also thought of other ones,
preference for luxury, so
how much you actually
like a status symbol.
Taxes could be another one depending
on what state you're from.
So Uri Simonsohn did a nice study and
basically said, well,
let's actually look at
this scientifically.
And he took people who were moving
from San Francisco and Alabama and
said we're going to go to Pittsburgh.
And what would determine what house people
would buy if they're moving
from different cities.
And what he did was basically take
people the same exact income, right?
So money was not a question.
They had the same exact
means to purchase houses.
And so
what now was the kind of of the what,
how did people decide if they were
going to buy a big or small house?
Yep.
>> They were before.
>> Exactly, so
in a perfectly rational world,
the prices of the city your moving
to would be what we should look at.
Not the prices of the city
that you're moving from.
Right, this is a little crazy but
if you're moving from an expensive city,
you're buying an expensive house.
Doesn't matter the prices, doesn't
matter how the house actually looks.
So your preference for luxury,
or your family size or
any of these factors
that were controlled for.
It matters actually that
where you moved from.
So this is interesting, right,
because this is one of the biggest
decisions that we're going to
make from our wealth perspective and
giving up money in our lifetime.
And yet we're using it on a heuristic
that just doesn't make sense.
And you could tell, because after a year
these people either downgraded if they had
a big house, or
they upgraded if they had a small house.
So their preference is upon moving weren't
reflective of their overall preferences
and those were soon determined after about
a year living with this one decision.
Okay, the last little piece of this is
it's the environment around us that
matters.
Friction is terrible and that we
hate to give things up that we have.
And so this is base in the 1980s
in the savings world for
companies, when they were trying to
offer their employees a retirement plan,
it was called a field of dreams approach.
And what this meant was that they were
just going to throw out all of the savings
and options that you quoted someone.
So you get to pick which
asset class you want,
you get to pick how much you get to save.
All of these variables were
open to people to decide.
And what happened is that researchers,
and this was a good thing, right?
You give people more choice, if you give
them offers, they will save, if you give
them options, they will save, and
that's just kind of the resounding factor.
And what happened is that a lot of
researchers said this is very interesting,
but probably not correct.
And so they said, if we just give people
the option to save, how many people save?
And then if we give people
the option to save,
but we give them the kind of
automatic enrollment check box.
And in one case, we give them an automatic
enrollment with 3%, in one case, with 6%,
and in one case,
they don't have the automatic enrollment.
Now when you have the automatic
enrollment, more people saved.
But the interesting thing with the study
is that when you give people automatic
enrollment on 3 or 6%,
both the same number of people saved.
So again, it's not that you have
a preference, kind of like the clothing,
it's not that you have a preference not
to save, it's that there's too much
friction in between you doing
something and you not doing something.
And so by closing the gap of friction,
you're able to meet the intention and
action gap.
That's exactly what happened here, because
if you say, I have a preference to Save or
not save them these should be different,
because you actually have a preference
that is 3 to 6%,
the amount that you would save.
Okay, so I kind of said this as a joke.
My lessons equal behavioral economics
principles, but in reality,
we're thinking about the aggregate
fabric of human decision-making and
trying to apply that to the principles
of behavioral economics.
So when I say behavioral economics,
and I've been saying this a lot,
I just want to pause to give a definition.
Does anyone have a definition
that they'd like to share?
With us of what they think
behavioral economics is.
Crickets, I once did something to someone,
quick story,
if you ever want to get a friend mad at
you, they post something on Facebook,
and then no one responds, and
you do a 12-minute soundtrack of crickets.
[LAUGH] Very funny, okay.
Yes.
>> I guess how people either align with,
or deviate from, rational decision-making?
>> Yep that's beautiful.
So the long form explanation
that I usually say,
in typical economics there's a supply and
demand curve and
this is very nice in theory, but
a lot of times it doesn't work.
There are other factors acting on us,
that will deviate as from
a pure supply and demand.
So whether it be that other people
are around, or that the words on a label
are different, or that you think
you're going to lose something,
at some point we're going to deviate from
the perfect supply and demand world.
And behavioral economics seeks to
understand why we do that, how we do it?
And then the behavioral
academics seek to graph that,
and if you call it social science they
don't care as much about graphing, but
they still care about deviating
from the norm of rational behavior.
Cool, okay, so
we're on the same page as we go on.
Okay, so then the question is, okay,
great, Kristen,
we've got all these principles of
human behavior that apply to kind of
aggregate fabric of decision-making.
But we are in the product world and
we want to know how to apply this
stuff to our day-to-day life.
Day-to-day life as in building and
thinking about building products for
other people.
So for the past year and a half,
we've kind of outlined the process
that we take when we're thinking about
taking academic science and
applying it to the product world.
And I'm going to use a term that is
a little bit overdone in the Valley here,
if we go to Kansas, it'll be wildly
received, but hacking as a metaphor.
And so the concept of hacking really is
that, and this actually quote sums it up,
a hacker can find a tiny vulnerability to
get into a server and then remove this.
And so what this is,
is that hackers have a deep curiosity.
They look at the full system, and
then they attack the small details.
And that's basically how we think about
applying behavioral economics to product
questions, is that we
have a deep curiosity for
why someone is doing something,
their mindset,
we're looking at the whole system of
how they're making that decision.
And then we're finding that tiny
vulnerability to understand how we can
bridge the intention and action gap.
Okay, so I just want to give us a tangible
example of why a hacker is cool, and
if you know the target example,
you know that basically they hacked
in to the system in two ways.
So hackers had to figure out how to
hack into the credit card system.
And then they had to figure
out how to store it.
And the theory behind this, and
I'm not an expert in security although
I've tried to talk to the security experts
to validate this, they give me the head
nod that generically, this is correct.
That they basically,
there's a tiny instant [SOUND] before
the credit card is saved,
is encrypted, from when it's
taken to it's encrypted that
it's stored in this RAM store.
And at that second, they can pull
this because there's a vulnerability.
But the people still have
to get into the system and
still have to store it somewhere.
And then the interesting
thing about the Target hack,
is that the whole system was breached,
was that the way they got into it
was by exposing a vulnerability
in the vendor side of the system.
So the vendor servers,
it was a one-off, they could get in and
hack in through when people were
uploading their vendor documents in the,
kind of the auth system that
vendors would log in to.
They got in through there and
then were able to scrape the credit
card information through here.
So by looking at the whole system not
just one piece, but the full decision
making process they found
the vulnerabilities to hack the system.
Okay, so what I'd like to propose now, is
you can say that's a great metaphor let's
just try applying it to
a variety of things.
And we'll show you theoretically how
we can apply it to something like, food
consumption and then actually how we've
applied it in some of our consulting work.
So food consumption, it's a huge problem,
30% of the US is now obese.
And it's actually more impactful
when we look at childhood obesity.
So this is the scary chart that
gets more scary as time goes on for
childhood obesity.
So if we want to pause for a second, we're
going to basically say how would we hack
this system and take this system
down to a cafeteria level.
So Brian Wansink is a researcher
at the University of Illinois and
he does a lot of, if you're ever
interested in understanding more about how
to hack the food system, Mindless Eating
is his latest book, very nice.
But let's just talk about how
to hack the cafeteria system.
So any ideas?
Yeah, we want to get people to eat less or
eat healthier?
>> Smaller plates.
>> Yes, ooh, this is a seminal one,
basically we eat not with our stomach but
with our eyes.
If we have a smaller plate,
you'll eat less.
>> Labels, saying that this is fat,
this is not fat or [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yep, I would say labels in general can
work, depending on what the label is.
So generically how we think about
information is that it's very nice, but
if it's not surprising,
it doesn't really change behavior.
So if you think about calorie
labels in New York, very nice,
didn't make people eat healthier.
So there's a few studies, but plus or
minus a couple percentages, right?
But labels actually,
we'll come to this in a second,
could be used in a different way.
>> But not calorie labels, but
it would take like an hour to run
this off if you ate a cup of it?
>> Yeah, so giving somebody some kind of
an opportunity cost in their real life.
Very nice.
>> Put healthy stuff earlier.
>> Earlier, yep, very nice you could,
we'll get to another idea, but yep.
>> Getting rid of the trays and
things that make it easy to [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yep, so
this is actually counterintuitive.
Trays help you eat healthier.
And the counterintuitiveness is
that you can't take a salad plate,
if you don't have a tray.
And so
in places where you want to get salad,
you want to get people to take
an actual plate of salad that's bigger,
you want them to have trays
that can take two plates.
Yep?
>> [INAUDIBLE], so
right next to the cake have fruit and
kind of make it a binary decision, so
that it's easier to take the healthy one.
>> Yeah, so you're talking about
reducing friction, which is great.
So say we want to reduce
friction to healthy items and
add friction to non-healthy ones.
There's also this question of relativity,
of if you're comparing a healthy
versus a non-healthy thing,
is it easier to make the decision?
And it probably depends on
the person a little bit more,
as we think about their
mindset as they're going in.
How set are they on a healthy
versus a non-healthy.
Yep.
>> Defaults,
all plates should come with an orange or
salad already on them.
>> Beautiful, great idea!
Yep.
>> In the corner you can see that possibly
something [INAUDIBLE] be able to
have the option, but not visible.
>> Yes, ding, ding, ding, yes.
>> Shorten the time you're spending in
line, but more of the same options,
but then you make the line faster,
you could come back and
easily takes more if you want-
>> Yep.
>> [INAUDIBLE] take more [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yep, so maybe adding friction or
adding a wait-time, to things that
are unhealthy and decreasing it for
things that are healthy, yep?
>> Like in the picture, I mean if people
serve you rather than you getting your own
food they can control how much you eat.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
Paternalism, very nice [LAUGH].
So this is definitely one serving sizes
and having a control, just like a small
plates, can you get it so that it's
not that your eyes are eating for you.
Cool?
Okay,
we'll go through some
things that Brian tested.
So we have this putting the Broccoli,
and who says putting the good
things at the front of the line?
So this is the label idea.
Can we rename stuff?
But actually, make it seem more unhealthy.
[SOUND] So we say corn, people maybe
are attracted to creamy corn, right?
So if you're able to basically give
sexy labels to things people will
eat them more.
So if you go to a restaurant, you think
about actually it's just chicken, but they
put all these labels on why this chicken
is amazing, and it's been tested for menu.
That these types of descriptive labels
will increase the perceived value, and
help us choose them more frequently.
Actually for our next conference at start
up which is our annual conference we're
bringing in an menu expert.
He's very good at helping the relativity
of decisions when people are forced to
make a choice.
Hiding the ice cream, so
this is exactly what it is you close it,
you make it more opaque.
And what happens you
actually have to open it.
This is terrible right.
This takes a lot of effort to open it,
but in fact it actually works.
So one of the ideas that Dan always
prophecies to folks he talks to about, and
I don't know if he has
met any refrigerator, or
appliance makers to get them to do this.
But it would be,
why in the world do we have our fruit, and
veggie drawer in
the refrigerator to be a low.
So some of times it's very low.
And it's opaque, so you can't see it.
So if things are going to go bad, you
can't even see that it's going to go bad,
and you have to make an effort to open it.
How could we reduce the friction of having
the healthy stuff in the refrigerator
where what we open the most,
we see it the most, be less and
increase the chances that we'll actually
eat healthy on a day to day basis.
Okay, use of tray so
this is actually very nice
to get people to take a tray,
shrink the bowls.
So hiding things [LAUGH] this isn't your
paternalistic we're just going to make it
like an Easter egg hunt and hide things.
This is another kind of counterintuitive
one if you change how the food looks,
and this could be changing the bowl or
adding lighting.
Will actually increase how much
people purchase healthy food.
Offer a salad, so just purely asking
the question, do you want a salad?
So Michael asked me,
do you have video when I started.
I feel I should have video,
like maybe I should have video.
Right, just putting the question in your
head of do you want a salad will increase
people taking it.
Instead of putting it in
the front of the line,
you can also block the cashier
with the salad bar.
So people have to move around
it in order to take things.
And then this is the nice idea to have,
use the lines as a facilitator to
have people make better decisions.
So imagine that you had one line for
unhealthy things, and one line for healthy
things, or you had people pay cash versus
credit card for the unhealthy things.
So just adding friction helps people stop,
and think, and be a little more
rational than just reaching for
the cookie or reaching for the muffin.
Yep, yep, nope, so, yep?
So.
>> Do people ever get angry that you're
hiding the things that they want?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah,
so, you know I Google they do this, where
they move around things a lot, and so
I think there is some kind of
a question of, am I being manipulated?
Which is really your question of like,
how far can we go to manipulate people.
And kind of what I would posit that
we think is, we think that just
random of how if the cafeteria was
designed and it was purely random.
That this is somehow not
manipulation either.
In reality, somebody had to make
the decision to put something somewhere.
And so that decision has been made for
us, either intentionally
to help us eat better.
And If it's not intentionally,
then it's still being made for us, and
making our decisions that
we're not even aware of that
our decisions are being made by
this random algorithm, right?
And so the questions is,
do you believe in a random algorithm or
do you believe in somebody
actually designing a system?
And obviously, there are pro's and con's,
you say who's designing the system
matters a lot in that case.
But in reality, when you're thinking
about eating heathy, saving money,
saving energy, all these good things.
We get more liberties to design
the system, and be the choice architect.
But yeah, if you have people running
around and like digging for things.
There's no point system to that,
then there's definitely a line.
And actually as your building products
kind of the line is usually legal.
Right?
In deciding how far you want to go.
Even though it seems okay,
you're still basically,
you have a lot of rules and
regulations that you can't do.
Okay, so we're going to go out
with the next thought exercise.
So have you guys,
you guys go to this city, and there's this
There's this cab company and it has
facial hair on the front of the cab.
So there's this cab company and they,
cab company, and they take riders from one
destination to another, and they're busy,
and less busy times, and less busy times
are that's calm, Tuesday mornings and more
busy times are Friday nights, and drivers
can make more money on Friday nights,
because there is more people on the roads.
But the problem is that drivers
also have lives too, and
it's very difficult to convince them to
drive on Friday night when they also would
like to go out with their friends.
But on a Tuesday,
Morning very easy to get them to drive.
So we have this in proportion, we have a
lot of people wanting to drive on Tuesday,
not a lot of people wanting
to drive on Fridays, but
more people wanting to
take rides on Fridays.
So we can't, we got a question
says how would we convince people,
drivers, to drive more on
Friday than on Tuesday.
What would you guys say?
Yep.
>> More money, so
give them more of the cut on Friday
nights as opposed to on Tuesday mornings.
>> Yep, so that is definitely one answer.
For this we wanted to
take off the table money.
So money is interesting for
a couple reasons, but it's very expensive.
So if you think about building
a strategy based on money,
we could pay everyone to do everything.
Maybe if you're Google you can do this,
but most companies can't.
So we don't want to build a long
term strategy based on Money if
we don't have to.
That is definitely
a variable we can play with.
But we don't have to the other thing is,
that money brings
in more of a kind of kills
the interistic motivation.
And basically takes away
kind of any doing it for
the greater good aspect when you're
going to start paying people.
So imagine paying your kids
to eat broccoli, right?
Not so good, because then they wont,
they'll think they always need
to get paid to eat broccoli.
>> [INAUDIBLE] really want to go
somewhere on Friday nigh,t and
say this person wants a casual ride.
Do you want to take them?
>> Interesting.
Yeah, so basically,
beautiful women to drivers [LAUGH].
No, there is something how you make
it more attractive in general,
to have people drive.
>> [INAUDIBLE] drivers.
>> On Tuesdays.
So we're basically going to then say,
maybe we'll pay a bar to have,
just make Tuesday night
the night in San Francisco.
So kind of make it so
it's an even opportunity class.
This is very nice,
probably not as practical,
since Friday always has that
allure of Saturday after it.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Taco Tuesday!
So yeah,
Taco Tuesday is doing some of the work,
we would have to do a little bit more.
I don't know, what could do, We'll go
to other ideas for this later [LAUGH].
>> If you have other commitments,
you don't have to drive all night,
but you could drive from eight to nine.
>> Yeah, exactly, so are our people
opposed to full night, i think they have
to drive the full night, or are they
opposed to just driving an hour or two?
[INAUDIBLE]
want to help reduce drunk driving.
>> Interesting, okay.
So basically calling on
the altruistic motivation.
So typically we think that that
stuff is very nice but doesn't work.
As well as something else if you
think about global warming, right?
The worst problem ever invented.
You're basically trying to save the world,
you don't see the counterfactual
of the world actually being saved.
So for this to work we'd have to show them
the counterfactual of somebody getting in
an accident from drunk driving.
[LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> We'll think about that one,
come back to it, yeah.
>> You can make it fun, so
that you're kind of simulating what it
would be like to be out on Friday night.
But with the people in your car to
somehow make the driving experience.
>> Yeah, exactly, so yeah, so if we
understood that people actually want fun,
could we play to that.
And make it easier for them to have fun.
>> [INAUDIBLE] friends to drive as well,
so there's no fighting until later.
>> Interesting, so mutual destruction,
if I'm not having fun no one's having fun.
I like it.
I just don't want to be your friend
if you become a Lyft driver then.
Anyone else?
So this is how we approach the problem.
Basically said, okay, let's look at how
people are making the decision to drive,
and when to drive.
And then we're going to lay out the whole
process of how they make this decision.
And we'll figure out
when we can intervene.
Kind of like this hacker mentality, right?
We figure out,
how is a decision being made?
And then, where can we insert ourselves?
And so what we have is drivers
activate their account.
They set up the preferences for
the number of hours that they work,
they sign up once a week on
Wednesday to work the next week.
They get notified of their hours in which
they actually have their hours confirmed.
They drive and then they get notified for
how much they make while they drive.
And then if they want they can
pick up hours intermittently.
So with this flow, what we did is say,
where are people making the decision
to set their hours, anyone?
On Wednesday.
Yep, and where are they learning about how
much money they could make on a Friday
night over a Tuesday night?
Not on Wednesday, yep,
two days after they drive.
So then now this is kind of interesting,
right?
So we basically say we want to convince
drivers that they should drive on
a different day.
But we're telling them about the benefit
of doing it at a completely different
time, revolutionary.
But what if we told them about
the benefit of them driving at the point
they're making a decision?
So what we did basically is bring
the opportunity cost of their decision on
the scheduling interface.
And we said when you're
picking your hours,
you now know Fridays you can make 35 and
on Tuesdays you make 15.
My gosh!
And then we totaled it up for them.
And so at the end, they had a number
of hours and how much they would make.
Versus how much on average they could
make if they drove all Fridays.
We did this in different conditions.
We said this is very nice, but
what if we actually showed them how much
gain they could make by
working more Fridays?
So Fridays had that plus 15, right?
And so the average was Tuesday and
it was more money on Fridays.
And so that's also nice, but
we can also show how much they're losing.
So on Tuesdays we put a minus 15 and
which would work better, right?
So basically this is how
we think about testing.
We say okay we have a hypothesis,
we have a theory of change.
Which is showing people the opportunity
cost at the point of decision is kind of
our theory, here.
And we have different tests.
We have different controls,
we think just showing them is nice.
But we could probably do ina gain and
a loss and
then we have a control where
there were no changes.
Yup.
>> [INAUDIBLE] but if say I did.
Could you also say, I want to work?
I'm guaranteed that I'll work
20 hours in the next week.
And right now they're having
incentive on Wednesday so
they're probably if anything
would be crunching on Tuesdays.
So if you wanted them to actually crunch
you could have that cross on Saturday.
>> Interesting, so
you're saying, get them-
>> So if they're like,
I still need ten hours
left to make my cut.
>> Yep.
>> That ten hours, you better make it.
>> I like this, because this is
actually how people think, so
they don't think in how
much they make per hour.
They think in totals of how much
they're going to make per week.
So that would be very nice,
kind of giving them a,
you said you wanted to make $400 this
week, and right now you're at 300.
You could work two Fridays or
five Tuesdays.
[LAUGH] What do you want to do?
And then have them sign off.
So get them kind of at this,
where they're feeling emotional.
>> Friday becomes their
last chance to [CROSSTALK].
>> Right.
Yep, very nice.
That's great.
Yeah, so any ideas on which
condition that we tried worked?
>> I feel like the minus 15
actually worked the best.
Because I would imagine that people
dislike losing more than they like
gaining.
>> Yes, you're correct here.
This is called prospect theory.
And they do dislike losing
more than they like gaining.
And so, all the conditions worked,
which is very nice.
And then that one worked the most.
No-
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> It's showing the minus.
So not all of the conditions but
the conditions that we tried to show
them the opportunity cost worked.
Okay so now we're going to do another fun.
What would we do to try to
reduce honking in India?
Okay so I don't live in India but we have
to realize that there is honking in India.
That happens a lot.
>> It's because they don't drive in lanes.
So you have to get them
to drive in lanes first.
Because it's a free for all.
The lanes don't mean anything in India.
So you honk to let people know
that they're behind you, or
that you're behind them.
>> Yeah.
So this is actually what their research
is, they found that when they looked at
people are they honking out of danger,
all the time?
>> I'm telling you I'm here.
>> Yep, so [INAUDIBLE] but
is it necessary?
On a scale of one to necessary they
measured, is it necessary that they honk?
What they realized is that
it was much more habitual.
[CROSSTALK] That people are doing this.
Yeah but
what you brought up was a very nice point.
There's one kind of thinking
in behavioral economics,
let's just make a policy which
we usually think works the most.
Right, if you just make
a law to prohibit smoking.
People would smoke less.
This is very nice.
And so here we are trying to hypothesize
on how to get people to smoke less.
And in general,
policy is one thing to go to.
Now obviously, this just takes
a really long time for most things.
So in the product world we
kind of get to hack that system.
And say yes, I understand
the policy would be much better.
But we are fast moving human beings and
we would like to get a change out sooner.
So in general, yes,
a policy to have lanes would probably,
given that you get over the adoption hump,
be the best.
>> If you were editing the product
you could put some horn back in
an uncomfortable place like on the roof.
Actively pressing the horn would
be just kind of uncomfortable.
[INAUDIBLE] work with existing cars,
you could make it so
you have to press three times
in order to get one honk.
>> Beautiful, okay, we're going to hold
onto that idea, hold onto that nugget.
[LAUGH] Any other ideas?
>> Make horns louder.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And what would that do, tell me more?
>> I feel like it would
probably cause a drown out of
noise because everybody's
honking at the same time.
Adding your honking won't help or
pressing the horn will be so
loud that it will startle you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yes,
yes, so the startle effect, I like this.
We can call it the my god.
So the reason honking is not great is
there's the negative externality to it.
And that it It impacts people
who aren't in the car,
probably more than the people in the car.
And so when we're designing the system
one of the things to plus or minus is
how much of a negative externality
are we creating for other people around?
So if we think that it's too
much of a negative externality,
that would be too scary for
us to implement,
because the of the comments people
are honking louder, but it's escalating.
>> So you can increase the negative
effect inside the car, but
in a non-dangerous way, you can make
the horn a really embarrassing sound?
>> Yes!
Okay, this is great.
And if you haven't watched the video,
somebody else sent it to Michael,
this is exactly what they did.
So they basically, they basically
had every time that you honked,
it would honk back at you and
you had to turn it off.
So both of you guys were right on of
basically what this did is that I'm
going to press the button, and
I know that I'm going to have friction,
I'm going to have to think to turn it off.
And so this got people to stop and think
before they actually started honking.
So when we think about a habit it's
usually done by just not thinking, right?
And if we want to stop a habit,
we want to introduce some friction.
And we want to make people think
before they actually complete the task
that is usually routine, yep?
>> Isn't that kind of dangerous, when
you're talking about honking and driving?
If you're adding friction before you do
something that's like a mechanism of I
need to let you know there's danger here.
Adding friction seems kind of.
>> This is true, so
in India this is the research that they
did prior to this is that they figured out
that people were honking out of habit.
And there's some percentage of things
that you actually don't want to and
it doesn't make you do something
before you honk, right?
So it's only after.
>> Right, but
unless people are honking out of habit
100% of the time there is a-
>> Yeah, but
this doesn't prevent you from honking,
right?
So there's nothing in between you and
honking.
>> But what you're saying though is
that you will, no matter whether,
I realize it doesn't prevent
you from honking, but
what you're saying is that it
introduces friction before you honk.
>> Yup.
>> And
if that happens 100% of the time, but
not 100% of the time are you
honking out of habit.
>> Yeah, I think you're on to something of
how much if we introduce thinking before
something in the way think too much in
something that we don't need to think in.
That should be instinctual and
the thing with danger zones like this,
we think actually are instinctual.
So we think that if you're going to be in
a dangerous situation that you would be
instincted did to do this.
And then we actually just
want to interfere and
make you think in times where
you could change that behavior.
But in general,
if you're in a dangerous situation,
the hypothesis was that you're not
going to be stopping from honking because
you're thinking that that's
actually an instinct.
Yep?
>> I think one other very good example
here is that you can see the fire alarm
here, or the exit door here.
It's a security exit door here if you
push the door you can hear the alarm.
So even if people don't
want to push that door,
they don't want to embarrass
other people in the room.
But in the case is that they can
understand the emergency issue is over
there's embarrassment so
I can still use that door.
>> Yep good analogy yep.
>> So did you say that when you once
honk it, it honks back at you and
then you have to push it again?
>> Yep.
>> So don't people get the habit of
honking twice to put it on and then off?
>> Yeah maybe so the net result of this
study was 60% reduction in honking.
>> But a lot of these sites,
these studies show what happens at
the beginning of introducing this product.
And you don't really know what would
happen if people were using this for
a long time.
Maybe they would get in
the habit of doing it twice.
>> Yep so this is a nice question just in
general about how behavioral economics
studies long term effects.
And in general, in a ideal world
we're actually studying much
longer term effects than we do so
for eating, or smoking, or
any kind of behavior change,
we need to really study longitudinal.
And there's this kind of first use, and
elongated use that people think of.
So you're right on, I think with this,
this is something where
you're just adding friction.
And again,
if you can get them over the habit hump
of actually doing it all the time.
Then the long-term effects, hopefully that
you don't need to keep doing the honking.
This is obviously a social
coordination effort, right.
If everyone's still honking and
then you're the only one who's changed,
it's a different story.
But the theory of the case is that for
some behaviors, if you can create a new
habit, that you don't need the negative
reinforcement to go on forever.
Other thoughts?
So this is, as I was talking about
kind of how we lay out the process,
this is what we did with an insurance
company in South Africa.
Where we basically said they want people
to go to the gym and we laid out,
we went to the gym,
we went through their whole process.
They have discounts at supermarkets,
they have fitness assessments,
they get their glucose tested.
They want people to go to the gym,
and so a coworker and
I went through the whole process and
then laid out for one specific behavior.
What are the big pieces
that we want people to do?
Where is that vulnerability and what
are the barriers to doing this action?
And then we apply behavioral
economics to these barriers.
So it's become kind of a very nice
understanding the full system,
looking at the details with
a curiosity for human behavior.
And we have the tools of these or
psychology we can kind of
work backwards and solve.
So again my big hypothesis in the theory
here is that the principles of human
decision making are actually
the principles of product design.
And so as we're product designers,
we're not just looking at asking users
questions, but we're looking at more of
the theory of how they respond to
big decisions in front of them?
And that we can narrow it down into
understanding that the environment is
important, small details matter,
and friction is a big determinant.
And many times we get this wrong, right.
We pay attention to
the things that don't matter.
We use our gut instinct, and
we hold onto things a bit too long.
So I'll leave you guys with some good and
bad news.
So the bad news is that over the last,
100 years ago 10% of our mortality was
determined by human decision making.
Any guesses for what,
how much is determined by now?
So how much do we affect our own death?
Decisions that humans
make affect human death.
>> 30%.
>> A little bit higher.
>> 50?
>> In between.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [CROSSTALK] You guys are math people.
>> Just kidding.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So 40% of decisions right now are,
40% of deaths are impacted
by human decision making.
And this means, this is all the cancers,
this is diabetes,
smoking that we actually control.
And this is good, this is obviously
terrible news, and this is good news for
people who are willing and
ready to create products and
solutions that can help solve them.
So the world is not getting any easier.
Danny earlier always says,
the Dunkin' Donuts B 2.0 is going to be
more unhealthy and less good for
us than the first one.
And so we have to figure out
mechanisms and product and
solutions to help kind of curve this 40%.
But the people in this room,
the people that we're friends with
are the people that do this, right.
Given the fact that the environment
can influence decision making,
this is a huge win for
product people right.
because it means we can
design the environment,
we can help people who have
intentions meet their actions.
And super empowering for all of us.
And that is all that I've got.
Do we have questions,
or how do you want to?
>> Yeah, we have some time for
questions, thoughts, suggestions.
>> Crickets!
Sorry.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you guys.
Yep.
>> I have a question about how gender,
because sometime people say
when you make the decision,
usually guys are supposed
to be more rational.
But you can see a lot of
examples when people buy iPhone,
and you ask whether they choose
the white color, or the black color.
The women usually give you answer,
I just like the white color.
Or they don't think like
why they really like it.
But when you see the case for
the guys they go the apple store, and
they have the whole plan.
But for
the last minute they change their plan.
So I'm not saying men are more
rational than the women.
But do guys have research
to show whether the gender
play a different role in
how they make the decision.
The rationale they use
a different way to show it?
>> Yep.
So two answers to your questions.
There's the nice one about individual
differences in general, and
how the field looks at
individual differences.
And in reality, there hasn't been too many
findings about how individual differences.
Like this person pays
attention to social proof, and
this person pays attention
to loss aversion.
That's just who I am, and
that is who I will be forever.
Instead, the field looks
at it like a mindset.
So in some instances, you have
the mindset, let's just do search and
browse which we were
talking about at lunch.
In some instances,
you're on the mindset of search.
you're in the mindset of browse.
In the search world,
you're more suscept to social-proof.
Sorry, in the browse world, you're
more willing to accept social norms.
And in the search world, you're not.
And so, its really not, but
in another world when I'm searching for
let's say shoes,
because I have no idea how to buy shoes.
I didn't, before I was very
susceptible to social norms, and
now I'm not as susceptible
to social norms.
And so its really the mindset that
we're going into a problem with.
So then the question becomes,
do women and men have different mindsets?
And I think we have different mindsets,
and different types of products.
So we may be more akin to in
the culture that we live in,
there maybe some times when
we have different mindsets.
But the question really is, when you're
thinking about designing a product,
what is your user's mindset?
And usually it's not determined by gender,
or age, or race, or culture even.
The second thing is that our environment
determines a lot of we're socially
brought up.
So, this researcher went to they said,
women seem to react negatively
to competition versus men.
And this is kind of been proven
across western society that,
you've had a Craiglist ad.
And then you have people applying and
you make it more or less competitive, and
get more men if it's more competitive and
less women.
Which is very interesting if we think
about the Cheryl Sandberg kind of
movement, as actually, women don't
respond as well to competition.
And the question was,
is this something inherent to women, or
is it something that kind of
society has brought us up?
So what he did,
is forget what the society was.
But in Africa, there was this group
which actually had the roles flipped.
So that women were the Patriarchs,
women were the people who led the society.
They were the ones who kind of
made all the decisions.
And he played the same kind of game,
where he played with women in the US,
he played that with women in this culture.
And it turns out they were
more competitive than men.
So the hypothesis there is that, A,
we don't really notice this is one
society versus all of the Western US.
We're not really sure, but
the theory is that it's a mindset, and
it's how our culture's grown off
that it's not an inherent difference
in us that would kind of
make us act differently.
When you think about
the differences of humans,
we've talked about fraternal
twins being different.
But literally the difference
between humans aren't that much.
And you think about that as an aggregate
world, we're actually quite similar.
>> So my question is how much
does the process habit behavior,
and number two is while there's
some of the strong emotions
that you can leverage to make
people change that behavior.
For some of us smoking they put sometimes,
they put the smoking kills and
some other ad and
also underneath that [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, so emotion, in general,
is one of the most powerful forces
of why we do the things we do.
So, we high level this to like
yes emotions, and no emotions.
Where you have something that
could bring you fear and
then you're pulled away from it and
you don't want to do it, or
it's something that could get you
excited and you want to do it.
So all these dating sites get you
very emotionally aroused with
pictures of nice looking people.
And gets you attracted to going
there versus something like
audit system that's going to get
you fear of losing your money.
So in general the emotions actually
kind of drive a lot of our behavior,
and it manipulating people's emotional
state at a point of decision is a big,
big tactic for
how we think about behavior change.
And it's going to be different with each
kind of product that we're talking about,
so there's no like one like
you should use fear here.
You know fear is very motivating,
but has long term negative effects.
When you're thinking about managing your
money you don't really want to lose it.
It may get you to act initially, but
what do you think about long term.
And so there's no, unfortunately most
behavior economics is never carbon copy,
here's a frame work, here's what you do.
And just, it's mostly
understanding the environment, and
just kind of hacking when, and
figure out how to apply it.
Did I miss a question?
You had another one.
>> Yeah, so,
I was wondering also what's the role
of habit to a person's behavior.
>> Yeah, habits are something interesting,
because there's kind of like habit thing
where product people really want to figure
out how to make their behavior a habit.
And we really want to
think deeply about that,
how much do we need to be in a user's
life that we're not interfering.
In general, I don't want to log in
to my accounting system everyday.
It just does not want to be a habit, and
yet, product teams are thinking
I need to increase engagement.
I need to increase engagement, and
in reality how much actually has to be a
habit, and I propose not too much, right?
So good behaviors, even saving money,
if you default us,
we don't have to think about how
much money we're saving everyday.
They're little decisions, but again,
we really want to think carefully about
why we want habits so we'll start there.
And then in general habits are something
where you want to think about,
when it fits in the user's
time of the day.
So we talk a lot about triggers
in the world of habits.
I'm kind of high on the horse of
figuring out when you can hack my day.
Is it before I get on the train?
Is it after I get off?
Is it right before I go to bed?
Brushing our teeth is like the biggest
universal habit that we have, and
there are two set times
a day that we do it.
There's some reward substitution
with the toothpaste going on, but
in general we have a time to do it,
and we have a place, and
there's some social coordination to it.
So, I'm not a huge proponent of having
a habit saying we should just form habits
with every product that we're doing,
because I don't think this is a good idea.
But we can be very thoughtful about it,
and
it's more about figuring out when during
your day we can hack your life, yeah.
>> I'm curious about like it's
almost an arms race here.
I'm going to channel [INAUDIBLE] Paris,
Google.
>> I just talked to him right before this.
>> Cool.
So, you probably don't
want to talk about that.
>> Yeah.
>> So basically,
if you're talking about this what
I want to be, and where I am.
Everyone wants to be on top of the news,
on top of their email,
on top of the information in their lives.
>> Yep.
>> And so, what we've begun to do is,
is create a lot of design interventions
that allow them to achieve this
immediate notifications if you get
a email, just information flying at you.
You're the first person to know that.
Whatever.
>> Yep.
>> And yet, there is a collective drain,
that's what I would argue,
that when everyone's doing this,
everyone is less effective, or
I, despite my pension,
am less effective than I was trying to do.
>> Yep.
>> There's two ways to read this, one, do
you just read that as a collective system
where we now need to re-hack across
all of these different products?
>> Yeah, I think it is a scary
world we're going into.
Right, so everyone's kind of vying for
your attention, and I've heard someone say
they've put all these Harvard grads
to make you log into Facebook more.
How are we supposed to fight against this?
And it's true, it's very, very difficult.
So, I think there's different
approaches that you can take.
One is kind of a policy, right?
We're going to say in general, apps can
only have x amount of notifications,
they can only trigger you so much.
They can get you at these times, but
they can't get you at these times, and
that's the policy way.
>> [CROSSTALK] I want to know
immediately when I got the email, right?
>> Yep, so some of this is a collective
consciousness of that this is not
good for us.
And then the policy would
have to come from that.
So I'm not a big believer in
policy being the fastest way.
But you can imagine web standards,
how web standards form is that there is
the uniform way of doing something became,
the UIs within mobile apps were
just kind of drag and drop then.
And people understood the framework
of how to act and behave.
So one approach would be understanding,
is there always an off setting to apps?
Right, where we basically add in
more features that let the user
either default themselves into not
having it go off at certain times, or
shutting it on silent at certain times,
or only letting certain things through.
And so there's the mechanisms of defaults
that's missing from this system right now.
Literally, we're just not able
to turn off or say what we want.
And if we can't default
ourselves into a better state,
then apps are just going to keep coming.
So if we can't say no,
you can't do that, then the user
has to have some control over that.
And then there’s this, just in general,
kind of, how do we prioritize our time,
and I don't think we're there yet, where
we understand that this is a problem.
So there's some social coordination there,
as well, to get this to be a problem.
And so it's now looked upon that you
answer your email quickly as like a very
good thing.
So if you can create a social norm,
even within a small company, that this is
a bad thing, you could probably help
with how people go about their day.
Now we can't change the whole world, but
these kind of team related social norms
are very powerful to get people not to
reward behavior like responding
to an email right away.
>> I just can't help thinking that the end
user's not only the winner here, but
insist that maybe they
stop smoking as much.
But also potentially a loser,
who is sort of being guided toward
behaviors that they may not
have chosen to do otherwise.
Imagine that you are not the cafeteria
trying to get [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yeah, so the good news though is that
the people who are doing the **** things
have learned this long ago.
So we're preaching really to the people
who are trying to change big behavior.
because the magazine stands,
Buzzfeed, they've got it, right?
It's the non profits.
I talked to this gal who
was running Learn Up, and
she's trying to get
people to apply to jobs.
So low income people, they'll apply to
jobs at Staples and Walgreens, right?
And I'm like, hey Alexis, we just need
to add a deadline, so that people have
a time to respond, because if you add
a deadline, we've done a test before.
It increases their response rates by 10x.
She's like, there is no way that I could
take that service away from people.
Because we want to give the service of
having them be able to apply whenever.
So the mindset really has to change for
people who are trying to do good things,
because they're going uphill, right,
against human behavior, and in reality,
we react very well to deadlines.
Right, they're self control mechanisms for
us.
But the mindset when we're trying to
do these kind of nice behavior change,
you talk to a non profit, and
they're just clueless about some of this.
So I agree, it's something where if you
say, in reality, we talk to Zinga folks,
and they understand this.
We're not teaching them a ton of, although
we think we can teach them how to get more
enjoyment from games and
design experience better, so
that people are happier if they're
wasting this amount of time, regardless.
[LAUGH] No but you think about designing
an experience like this, and you think,
how would you do it so
people are better off?
And actually we could do it, so
people are better off, right,
this is not their motivation.
Yep?
>> Do you mind talking a little bit more
about the browse bug versus the search
bug, where you can comply to social
norms versus not complying to social
norms as it applies to product design?
>> So if you think about certainty, so
if I were to hand you a coupon, and
I were to either hand it to you when
you're at the check out of a store, or
if I were to hand it to you right
as you were getting out of the car,
which would you be more susceptible to?
>> When I get out of the car.
>> Exactly, this is what social proof
is to browse and search is, basically,
you think about someone's certainty
in what they're going to purchase,
their certainty in their decisions.
And social proof works best
in uncertain situations,
when we don't actually know what we want,
or we don't know the right way to behave.
So basically, you're browsing for
something, you don't really know.
If somebody says, 80% of people
have bought this, you're like,
thank you very much,
this will go into my decision framework.
Versus if you say,
I actually really want this,
telling me that 80% of people
already bought something else.
Much harder to convince me out of it,
but it's not who I am,
it's a mindset of how I'm
approaching my product decision.
>> Have one more question?
>> Or one more joke?
>> A small administrative question,
actually.
>> If this is administrative,
I'll take it after class.
The website redirect is down, I know.
>> So I guess I was going to ask
something sort of related too.
Obviously, you guys are talking about
positive behavior change, and clearly,
there's companies out there that are
trying induce negative behavior change or
self-serving behavior change for them.
>> Yep.
>> So as individuals, though,
what would you say are clues
that you can look out for
as you start falling into
the funnel of being manipulated?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Interesting, so
I think you want to figure out if you're
bridging the intention action gap.
So does the user have
an intention to do something,
and are you helping them
then complete this action?
So, for instance,
you think about doing diabetes.
Doctors are people who are saying I think
you need to exercise this much, and
I think you need to eat this much, and
I think you need to take
this amount of insulin.
And this is very paternalistic of them
to tell us this, because in reality,
what should happen is they should take me
personally as an individual and say you,
personally, given all of your stats,
need to do something.
Or they should say,
Kristen, just figure it out.
You should be able to say
how much you have to eat and
how much you have to diet and
how much you have to exercise.
When in reality, these things are very,
very difficult for
an individual to figure out themselves,
and it's very difficult for
a doctor to just prescribe me
personally a recommendation on this.
And so what we end up doing is
the system is very noisy, difficult for
me to figure it out, difficult to even
give me a personal recommendation.
In this case, we're better just giving
a recommendation to a group of people
who are in their mid 20s and
what they should do.
And you think about that kind of thing.
You're saying, yeah,
I'm being paternalistic and
I'm telling everyone one thing
that I think they should do.
But in reality,
you're making a decision on my life much,
much easier because there's no way
that I could figure it out by myself.
And there's no way that you personally, as
a doctor, could give me one prescription.
So I think you really want to
think intention action,
is it going to be harder for
the user to figure it out?
because a lot of times,
we think we're data engineers,
you have these data engineers at Google
saying, can't they just figure it out?
Well if you can't figure it out,
how do they figure it out?
And so, giving people choice
sometimes makes them worse off.
Too many choices in 401(k),
people don't choose to have a retirement.
This is terrible, right?
>> Okay, let's [CROSSTALK]
>> No, it's terrible, no,
we need one joke,
I can't end up, it's terrible.
[LAUGH]
>> All right,
let's thank Kristen for that.
>> [APPLAUSE]